life is short is so pleased to have bud
light seltzer as our presenting sponsor
listeners know that we're big fans a bud
light seltzer it's a delicious hard
seltzer from bud light but it has no bud
light in it that's right each one is
just 100 calories 5 alcohol by volume
and gluten-free the retro summer pack
has been our go-to drink it really has
we've been lucky enough to like spend
some time with family at the lake and
doing all those summer things never far
away is our retro summer pack i mean i
love that summer ice it's so hard to
beat that i know you like the blue
raspberry a relative of ours they went
crazy for the cherry limeade and thought
and thought you're cr how are you not
enjoying this one the most so we love
partnering with bud light seltzer to
bring you some of our favorite summer
memories and we've got more in store
later in the show so stay tuned
[Music]
we surveyed two people
and asked them to come up with who won
family feud recently
that's a really roundabout way of
bragging that we
won
family feud you both have to win family
feud uh we did it was so exciting and um
the most exciting thing is that we we
won it for uh the hole in the wall gang
camp
what a great charity uh they just lost
one of their one of their
main camps in connecticut to a fire and
they're starting to rebuild they started
august 18th so want to wish them good
luck and um
pat ourselves on the back a little bit
and technically this is the second time
second opening
uh of of a show that we've talked about
family feud it's a big deal for us but
you know what how many times are you on
family feud in your life i know we
should milk it it's worth a double story
in fact i dare say we might talk about
it again
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my fellow
family feud winning
uh co-host and brother christian no one
will ever be able to take that away from
us i know champions ah didn't that feel
so i mean i
it's a little embarrassing how good it
felt
to me
when it happened yes it felt really good
but you know also it's
it's like relief
because the two of us did the fast money
the bonus round oh man and for me
this i mean not only is it
nerve-wracking being on tv and having to
answer those questions with all the you
know
it's also an iconic set oh yeah it's
it's it was nerve-racking yeah it was
and um and all this money is on the line
for this great charity hole in the wall
game um
so i was nervous seemed nervous as the
bonus round was going i knew my first
few answers were terrible
and i started to think
what if i shut the bed on this to the
point where i get like
seven points in the entire round because
i knew the first three were going to
yield almost the first couple were terry
were uh
watching it back because i didn't watch
that part i was in a booth i was like be
backstage with headphones on so i wasn't
watching you do that so it was really
cool to get to see you slash
it was fun you could tell i was nervous
yeah yeah and especially after those
first few answers because because i knew
you were upset with yourself like really
no jay i mean the dumbest thing i said
was j what j blank j blank we asked a
hundred people jay and then jay you know
i said jay jaywalking i said j muse
because
i had just been talking to him he's the
one i did the face off against james
kevin smith's team so we played against
kevin smith so he was fresh in my head
jay played for those of you who don't
know jay played um jay from jane simon
bob uh kevin smith's movies and um yes
or jay
jay muse was jay muse was very excited
that you guessed him but he was very
excited i think the number one answer
was jay leno
uh i said jay walking i i wonder if j i
wonder who else was on that list anyway
our mother was like j lo she kept
yelling j lo really i saw with my our
mom
what did james think you saw with james
james was
very happy yeah he i thought he did well
he had a good showing yeah he had a
funny moment they cut a lot of the inner
play yeah
cousin rich was great shout out to
cousin rich he really helped us diana
was fantastic
we had a good team
and here's the point yeah all details
aside we all had
good moments not good moments i had some
here's the point we won right
here's the bigger point hole in the wall
gang
one
why are we giving an update on our
weekend oh very well said why are we
giving a weekend update if you will
uh well
i'll tell you why because our guest
today i almost said tonight
well it might be tonight for some of you
defense when you want to listen yeah our
guest right now is um or later whenever
you're listening is uh it used to be the
host of weekend update on snl the very
funny the god one of the funniest uh snl
performers i think cecily strong she is
um you slapped your knee as you said her
last name yeah why i i don't know but i
i'm afraid that it didn't come oh
through okay it's cecily strong
yes and then i slapped it right after
the strong you said it slapped it on the
strong you successfully strong strong
who cares uh cecily strong is known for
doing
characters that are a little bit more
uh avant-garde or not avant-garde
they're very specific yes yes um the one
that comes to mind is the girl you wish
you'd never started a conversation with
at a party
uh and she does a lot of she does
jeanine pirro she does
great impressions great impressions and
pretty brilliant on that show she is
she's always been one of my favorite
performers on the show but now she's
written a book that is i can't recommend
enough we talk a lot about it today um
it's called this will all be over soon
and she wrote it
uh right before during the pandemic
actually it was uh her life was she was
going through a lot of dealing with a
lot of uh
tragedy and
some
romance and a lot she was dealing with a
lot as we all were it's not funny um it
is it is it is funny it's heartbreaking
it's it's very honest it's written in a
very
real it's raw it's it's i loved it um
it's
it's it's all uh kind of predicated on
the death of she lost her cousin uh in
january two months before the lockdown
and then she started a relationship that
was kind of
it's she details it all like very
honestly and and in many cases very in
very humorously
uh and she uses it's it's written in
journal form she uses text conversations
that she had with her cousin it's um
if anyone's going through anything like
this it's a great examination of grief
it's a very personal
i think beautiful examination of it and
um
and regardless of what your relationship
is to grief and and however you're
dealing with that uh everyone's gone
through the pandemic everyone's gone
through the experience of being in
lockdown and so i think it really i
think it i think everyone could uh
get something out of this book okay
endorsement yeah oh i loved it so we're
going to talk about that and snl and so
much more with the
very bright ver very funny uh and now i
know great author cecily strong
life could be a dream
[Music]
yeah thanks for having me it's such a
pleasure because i um i fee have you
you've seen what about bob yeah of
course
well i'm not crazy
i know you're not like bob wiley um but
i i keep thinking about that scene maybe
because i saw it recently
how
adamant he is that people have to get
this book so i keep i
keep thinking about him in terms of the
baby steps i'm like you gotta get
cecily's book i i'm holding it up right
now um
because it's it's meant so much to me
it's so beautiful and funny and and so
honest it's like um odd now to see you
because i feel like i know you so well
i'm sure people have been saying that a
lot
you know i it's actually it's great
because i'm i'm
sometimes awkward and
you know i stumble over words so it's
like i'd rather someone read that and
then i can meet them it's like oh yeah
so now you kind of you know me
what was the impetus for writing was it
simply to get
these feelings out get these very raw
emotions onto a page yes i mean that's
what it was at first for sure uh
and i think because we've been i'm used
to like my body is used to writing on a
tuesday i guess because of snl and then
those two weeks were just so bad
um
those two weeks i was quarantined in my
apartment that's how kind of how it
started how i started writing and did
the the essay that went to new york
magazine at first and then i just
i got some nice response and it felt
like people were
had found things in themselves or it had
it was useful to them and then i
i that's kind of made me keep wanting to
keep right then
no because it was like worst case
scenario it just it's i do therapy
right right but you i
it's true i guess this was which this
must have been a form of i mean yeah you
you you articulate that much better than
i just did a couple times in the book um
you start speaking to
whoever it is you're writing to as
though
they were an entity which i thought was
really interesting yeah and i think like
that was very helpful in a time of you
know such isolation and as somebody
who's like felt lonely
and i which i think a lot of us do it's
like
i'm having an intimate conversation with
somebody do you know i always think of
the regina spektor song aquarius
but she says dear someone in the shadows
yeah felt like a similar thing
yeah yeah i'm an aquarius so i have to
listen to that song
you only listen to a query to get into
the club yeah
the age of aquarius is
well yeah it's written in diary form but
it really did have that feeling of a
deeply personal
uh
memoir of a doc these diary entries that
at times
maybe we weren't even meant to be i
wasn't meant to be reading it was very
revealing but also like you said about
other people's response i had the same
one which is um i i identified with so
much of what you're talking about and uh
certainly
you're grappling with grief and and
during this time in isolation it was um
it was it was really important to me it
was i really connected in a way that
that was comforting so uh thank you and
i i can't wait for people to to read it
well thank you that's kind of comforting
felt like well that's how i can share
him then
and he strikes me the way you describe
him so beautifully he strikes me as
somebody who would have certainly
appreciated that and and um wanted that
to be in the world wanted that to be his
legacy absolutely yeah
yeah it's a beautiful tribute to him and
um
again like the the and the text exchange
that's also what struck me was i i've
been my grandmother died and she passed
away and i know you can't it's that it's
a difficult word to say that's like a
weird harsh word yeah
there's something so definitive and kind
of like it it falls with like a thud
it feels like i said when it's like
when you're
angry sad yeah that's like when it's
like they died you know and it's like
and that that's like that happened to me
they died and that happened to me and
like passed away feels more when you're
in that place of this is i'm talking
about it in a non-angry way in a loving
way yes and and maybe even in a
beginning way in in the way that uh
you know you know that death could be
i'm hoping is just a beginning of
something and uh yeah something i've
been
struggling with i'm sorry also before i
went into that i'm sorry about your
grandmother oh that's always tough yeah
it's it's it's interesting so that's
like you know because she's
um she was 104
yeah jeans good jeans i hope i hope i
have another
i have another one who's still alive
who's 104. um wow
i'm sure you're used to this having lost
some a couple people actually very close
to you is that
uh do you find that you have these um
kind of pat answers like for
you know when you're having small talk
about grief like when somebody
says
you mention it as something that
happened um and they say oh i'm so sorry
about your grandmother i find myself
saying yes but she was a she was old you
know it was 104 and
um but it's almost for them it's not for
you it doesn't feel like it hurts any
less right right well i do think
i mean i think there are different
losses and there are some that are
we as a society can sort of feel better
about and knowing that someone if they
lived a full happy life
and full of joy
or love at least but i do think it's
like i'm always gonna say sorry because
it's not like
i don't think it's ever
like a piece of cake for anybody
it's not a it's not a pleasant thing
still and just like all of us
dealing with our own mortality there's
always that also and so it's not
easy even in a very only selfish way
and not in the not bad self right it
just means you know about us
well that well that's what impressed me
because that's something i've struggled
with and it sounds like you have and and
uh i'm sure we will continue to uh
struggle with mortality but um
what's what really impressed me about
owen and the grace in which he
passed away was how he
there was something very
courageous about how he faced it without
fear which to me is like
remarkable i mean what what a testament
to a person's character i mean i still
don't quite understand it and you know
my editor early on was asking me
about that and i was like well i don't
know and i really was just trying to
explore that because yeah the idea to me
of living with that and not just being
stuck frozen and
like i know i have so much health
anxiety i'm so afraid of it and it was
just like he said i'm going to beat it
and
that was that
well but also when he realized he
couldn't it was that moment of um
where he's unbelievable where he thought
that to me is like and you you talk
about him as though he were
in terms of him being a superhero and uh
um heroic which um that is the i think
that's
that's a true strength and
characteristic of a heroic person and
you hear i you know you hear about them
in movies and they're portrayed in books
and stuff but but um
to actually know somebody who faced
death that way is uh
it's it's remarkable yeah his doctor
like
that story that's what um lita brought
up at his service and that is
when he was told just um giving the
background yeah when he was his sister
i'm not telling you yes who i think of
as my sister we call each other the
strong sisters now but when uh when
the doctor had to tell owen and he was
alone you know they weren't in there
with them at that point and she said
we can't shrink your tumor and there's
really nothing left and you know i don't
even know how you worded that so i'm not
even gonna
know how to work i know that you'll have
hours
before you slip into a coma and passed
away and she said to leta a lot of
people try bargaining with you at that
moment it's really tough and that makes
me very sad and owen just said well
thank you for all you've done and thank
you for trying
yeah that's um crazy
crazy i mean uh because i get like you
your writing is so it's so honest and um
it's it's so real that i i it was easy
to put myself there uh and i and owens
is as well i mean i love the way you you
include text conversations between you
and lita and owen and it's that to me is
um
some of the funniest and and most
heartbreaking stuff you know uh
but it's it's funny it's
you're all such good writers and and um
that was a moment where i thought i
could only hope i can only aspire to
have that kind of courage you know yeah
yeah that that grace um
i i think about the end i think about
how will i accept the our the fate
that's coming to all of us
um
i think about it a lot and and to to
read about somebody who chose that path
who was so courageous is it's inspiring
it was really inspiring it's yeah and i
mean i don't know about you but i find
it it's very it's calming to me too
because i feel like i'm also somebody
that for whatever reason
throughout my life there's been times
where i'm like i'll
like spin myself into
this
you know anxiety attack about dying and
then you know the only thing i can like
the one thing years ago i said it was
like well all i can wish for myself is
that i accept it in that moment and that
there's some kind of that i'm not scared
at the end i know
bargaining was is an interesting word i
imagine that's
that's probably right now what i would i
would def i'm sure i know i would do
that well what if right how about i just
can we just try a surgery how about oh
you know
yeah i remember seeing that in a man on
the moon in the andy kaufman movie and
he's well okay well go and do this and
i'll try this uh experimental thing and
um did you have reservation any
reservations one once you decided this
was something that you wanted to put out
into the world and you compiled um
these writings
what were your reservations about
sharing it
and and and and also says like how how
weird is it now to be talking about
something that was
you know with somebody who's relative
stranger
uh how weird is it to be talking about
something that is so deeply personal i'm
somebody that can have a three-hour
conversation that i'd be like well we're
going to stay up on that we have to talk
about this and get hash this out so that
doesn't feel
weird to me i'm okay with sharing with
somebody who's
not who is wants to share as well my
reservations i mean the ones that i feel
like aren't tied to any kind of
nasty self-deprecating negative
you know
thinking about what other people think
of me was just i just wanted to make
sure
everybody
was okay with me sharing it you know
because it's like i'm the one sharing it
it's not really they're not doing it and
so and and everyone really was and
you know leta and ed and laura i sent
everything i wrote pretty much as i was
writing it to it every person that i
mentioned your grandfather cecil struck
me as such an interesting uh all a lot
of your relatives i love that they have
these cheeky nicknames he's cecil i will
just oh i'm cecily i know oh weird it's
funny and people will
do that the opposite they'll call me
cecily
oh
some people because cecil demille i know
who knows oh yeah people pronounce their
names weird that's actually tyson
what are you sisterly
her eye is where my e is and my e is
where her eye is oh lord oh cecily italy
yeah yeah yeah
exactly that's stupid uh i uh i'm so
glad it is out uh in the world and i'm
glad you had the
courage i guess i mean it is courageous
to some of this stuff is not
it's also not all flattering was that
therapeutic what was what did that feel
like to to describe this burgeoning
relationship that was kind of stalling
amidst well definitely and that was you
know early on like there was a fear
about
writing about that but it was kind of
like
even if it doesn't work out it's like
that part of my story won't change then
it didn't work out but i am going
through that at the moment
i know a lot of people that have
like my i remember people coming to me
and saying i've done the same thing
writing these notes and it's sort of
that's that little bit of magical
realism like well let me just pretend
things are great and here's what i would
say to you then yes if we were talking
and it's just like giving yourself that
a little bit of delusion but in a
comforting way
it is it's i mean getting anything out
and and i imagine
being so thorough about your feelings
and about what you're going through and
getting that getting that out must have
been
you must feel connected to
strangers you must feel very
what does it feel like i've never done
anything like this yeah i mean certainly
i think there are it's very nice the the
connections that we have and there's
been and i'm sort of because of owen i
feel like and and not calling things
coincidences i'm i'm excited about those
connections and it means something to me
when people say they felt
they related they understood and this
mattered to them
um and then i think also you know it is
good to get it out there and i always my
dad and i had to talk about it recently
and he was kind of like you know part of
it makes me sad or something i was like
why
and he said because of like the early
stuff and i was telling but dad we are
where we are now which is like what a
happy thing and it wouldn't yeah to me
it matters more that we are where we are
now because it wasn't always easy and
because it's then i'm it's honest and so
when i say i love you it's like i say i
love you with all this history and it's
like it's just more honest
and i think it lets us celebrate more
like the whole point is to yes but
obviously it's about the tough things
but then the point is to celebrate
everything we get we get to celebrate
well it was your father he was referring
to so and again you're very so honest
about all this that the the divorce and
uh the most poignant thing uh way you
described that was was doing so through
the lens of um
yard plants
you know you describe your yard and i
grew up in the same way i grew up i had
a very similar my parents were
they were great gardeners and there was
beautiful flowers everywhere and just
over the years they're still together
but
to see that change that kind of
landscaping change yeah it's it really
struck me it was really beautiful now
you say you're struggling to keep basil
plants alive i'm wondering how your
green thumb is
you know it's still it's not great
um but i enjoy it so much and i too i'm
able to
cook with some of the things and i have
calla lilies again and
every now and then like some lily will
pop up and i'm like ah i i'm pretty sure
i planted that it's like a little it's
like a kid with a science experiment
still well you exact you said it
perfectly about the raspberries i
remember that feeling i still get that
feeling sometimes i blueberry bushes
near where i live in massachusetts and
um yeah there's just there's a real
thrill of just getting to kick them off
the bush i think i'd like that idea
which you you
you say so well in the book you i l you
like the idea of eating the raspberries
more than the actual right fruit yeah
it's true it's really i have a peach
tree for the people that lived here
before me had a peach tree which i
didn't know was a thing
that you could have in new york but it's
like a similar thing where i keep
i'm like taking a bite and it doesn't
you know i don't know how to grow
peaches so
but i definitely am always like i'll eat
this hard peach
because it's here yeah psychologically
it's like ah there's nothing like a
ripe peach but it's really really
cardboard hard peach yes yes it tastes
pretty good
yeah there's a little moisture in there
it looks very green where you are cecily
uh are you in so that's new york yeah
that's hudson valley
wow oh oh you're still upstate yes yeah
oh cool oh great oh okay um
and also again not to dwell
that's a labor how much i love the book
but i also loved um
just getting to relive my own experience
in those first few weeks of the pandemic
and through your own um and that's that
is something that if if you can't relate
to the grief part i would encourage
uh anybody to to you know start reading
it just just to
just in the hopes that it might conjure
some of your own feelings about those
early days the pandemic and i realized
how much i had buried and how much i
wasn't addressing uh just by reading
your book and recognizing similarities
so
again thank you i i think that's like
one of my also favorite things to hear
because i'm you know i worry that like i
see how much everybody's like well we're
moving on now we're back open
everything's fine and it's sort of i
don't know that we've really
taken much time to like
are we fine we just went through
something insane that i think is going
to have ramifications and i wish people
would check in with themselves and it's
meant so much any time someone there's
been moments where people have said to
me like
i'm hearing that i read that and i don't
think i've been grieving this and it's
like
i hope that people get a moment with
themselves to
to think about it
i didn't know this that you were um
as a kid you were obsessed with snl but
specifically with phil hartman i find
that lovely
man
it makes it it makes sense that's like
because you're
you both have a real connection to the
truth uh your writing is this way but
like i i always felt that way about your
characters uh
certainly the ones on weekend update
they all they felt so and i'm sure a lot
of people agree that they felt so on
they felt so real they felt like the way
people talk and not not even dialed up
that much yeah that's what
hartman's felt like to me yes there's
something about and i think he is
similar
um
it's you're making me think about it
like his just somebody that's like he's
this straight white man with confidence
who's just like
doesn't know sometimes doesn't know like
something can be happening in the
background and he's like everything is
great here you know it's just
it makes me laugh so much i think like
that is when a beck bennett always makes
me laugh because he has a song oh he's
got that that like i'm commanding the
room and it's like
totally so confident but wrong
yes that's the best everything's under
control even like unfrozen caveman
lawyer was like that like well ladies
and gentlemen you know like he's kind of
blind to the absurdity of it
how specific are those characters
because they feel so your characters
they feel so specific um
uh the the person you don't want to meet
that at a party uh
you know the girl that you got stuck
with at a party where
is that is that just an amalgamation of
of people that you've met yes and i
think um it started by making fun of
myself and then but then also thinking
about
my
straight male friends stories where
they'd like
started talking to some girl being like
she's cute and then like oh wow i can't
believe what she just said and i can't
get out of this
i have no experience with that cece i
don't know what you're talking about
it's funny someone asked me like well
what about aren't there men like that i
was like well usually if a man
approaches you it's like uh
right away i was like i didn't approach
him i i'm not
how do i the onus is not
right it's on him yeah
but i think like she's certainly more
real and specific and i remember there
was someone else on facebook or
something it really is like that i wrote
in 2012 at first which is like facebook
was the big social media and somebody
had written around the election like
after obama went like wow you all seem
so happy and that makes me so sad
and then it's like
what a thing to say oh i guess you're
smarter than the rest of us then if
you're sad if you're the guy like
in the corner while everyone's dancing
you must be smarter than everyone
yeah exactly and there's a pride in that
there's a what a weird thing to be proud
of and to lord over people right and
just i think that is so
like someone that checks their phone
when they're talking to you
and the reason she gets everything wrong
is because she's not actually
it's just
the only reason she's using any kind of
zeitgeisty thing or issue is to just
shame the other person or to say you're
dumb and i'm smart and now my friends
over there and i yeah
yeah it's all self-serving but i feel
like cecily she is also such a product
that's why that character is um
there's something iconic about it
because and so of its time because it's
it's uh she's such a product of
social media you know like people play
that out on social media but then to
have a conversation with somebody who's
so used to like either ranting or
posting and running away you know like
that type of communication was all like
outrage based yeah so um perfect that's
a lot of fun and i think even so and
then cathy ann i think is the other one
i would say probably other characters
are bigger and more about getting to be
a clown and have fun but certainly cathy
ann too was like
i just wanted to have someone who's like
this person is not preaching to you i
just want to be like it's
everything that's being called politics
lately is like it's not that's not
politics that's just like basic human
decency and it was like that shouldn't
let's not even argue about that point
let's have a crack addict tell you
that's what that is
that's really perfect yeah
[Music]
this segment is brought to you by bud
light seltzer's new retro summer pack
these summer days
really bring me back mid to late august
where you feel that the pressure to
really like make the most of each summer
day here's the biggest problem with that
time um bud light seltzer didn't exist
yet no unless you had a time machine
where you could bring some bud light
seltzer back to the 80s yeah most people
didn't have that no but now bud light
seltzer is kind of doing that with their
new bud light seltzer retro summer pack
it's a new tie-dye pack it features
three throwback flavors reminiscent of
those summers uh of yesteryear of your
yeah um the ones where you know you're
growing up and you just wanna play all
day and you can still play you can play
with bud light seltzer now the three
flavors are blue raspberry summer ice
and cherry limeade and i'm happy to
report i had each of those flavors
yesterday whoa that is i almost said it
was a wasp whilst sitting in a kayak oh
how nice this is great for the first
time ever fans can also purchase these
out of sight flavors these what
flavors that are not within sight uh you
can buy these new flavors in a new form
with bud light seltzer retro summer
icicles
great for a hot day oh man if the days
have been hot if you really want to cool
down and again it's the same flavors
blue raspberry some rice cherry limeade
and those flavors will i'm sure sparked
some summer memories because they're um
they taste like childhood yeah so just
grab some friends play some tunes and
enjoy the vibes get it delivered right
to your door you can find a retailer
near you at bud light.com delivery or
pick it up at your local neighborhood
grocery store or convenience store or
liquor store right any any store that
you have to walk into or get into
somehow
hello hello
[Music]
i didn't know this that you in high
school you were expelled you got
expelled for bringing weed yeah
how much weed did you have it was
an eighth i think it's like the oh and
like when did i last say an eighth it
was like i haven't said an eighth since
2002.
since i said a dime bag right
just like the worst shittiest as
schwagweed
right and i didn't even have anything to
smoke it in but it was the first
bag i'd ever bought and they found and
we had a new superintendent who was very
like zero policy so i had two other
friends get expelled during that time
but of course it was like
problematic to me that at the same time
you know athletes would not get expelled
you're important to us and you're not
how long how long cecily did you get
expelled for well it wound up being only
for that
semester because then i was welcome to
come back my junior year but by that
point i felt really bad there and and
then um i was going to i missed too many
credits gym credits so i was going to
have to be a fifth year senior because
of jim oh my god consumer education
and it was sort of like i can do summer
school for anything but like not jim i
can barely judge him
oh my god
was so what happened wait so did you so
on that why did you graduate well i
dropped out my junior year i started i i
was also like struggling with depression
at that time yeah so i missed like a
year at least of or about a year of
school probably total and then um but i
went to art school my senior year and i
did correspondence courses and they
don't have
gym requirements at art school or
consumer ads so i was able to get the
credits i needed and i graduated on time
was performing something that you
aspired to then was that something that
you was on the horizon for you or oh
yeah i mean i've been i took my first
drama class when i was three at my
priesthood
or something yeah and i did a lot of
community theater growing up so it was
what is
what's a drama class that was with three
years yeah what's a drama class yeah i
don't even know there were only three of
us in the class
um and i think we were supposed to do
like and this is like one of those
stories that it's like a memory but it's
not really it's what's been told to me
because those three but it was yeah we
were supposed to do the frog prince i
think but i didn't like the little boy
in the class and
where he was supposed to kiss me
we're not doing it and so we did that i
was in the shoemaker
oh he must have been
he must have been very disappointed he
probably wasn't very nice of me yeah
sorry he's listening
uh
and and were impressions something that
were uh
a part of your repertoire then even were
you doing impressions of like family
members and stuff it was but like i
didn't think i was an impressionist
especially when you see like really
great impressionists on uh but i mean
like as a little kid i love doing
impressions but my impressions were all
like the ones the big ones i can
remember i like doing the guy with the
shrunken head in the waiting room from
beetlejuice oh oh who just turns to look
at him not even the one he steals from
with the hair i had i liked the little
bald guy
like that and then i also like to do
the alien that pops out of his stomach
and spaceballs and then goes hello honey
those were my impressions
that's funny
yeah those are great but it's funny you
said something very i talked to bobby
moynihan on this show but he said
something similar and i and i which
surprised me that that he sort of
downplayed his ability to do impressions
and i think of both of you guys as very
talented and professionalist but i guess
when you're comparing yourself to like
you know the best of the best right and
you know hair and makeup
helps out with that a lot in wardrobe
but it's uh yeah i think as we were both
just like and also it's kind of
what you're drawn to sometimes when i
see a great impression i'm like huh
that's
really spot-on as if it doesn't
necessarily make me laugh as like the
alien from space balls makes me laugh
right right well
right that's the thing about some of
those i mean the cast that i grew up
with was you know like mike meyer the
dana carvey cast and
and i i said this to bobby too his his
impressions remind me a lot of of dana
carvey's um yeah in that he he captures
an essence of the a real essence right
they're not maybe like daryl hammond
specific but but uh there is a
specificity that is like
really like capturing that annie and i
think dana carvey too just like found
something funny that yeah you wouldn't
have seen and he amplified it he just
highlighted it yeah totally
who are you very confident doing i mean
who who would you say like who would you
audition with if you had to audition now
for s now the only one i really felt
like oh this is an obvious
easy one was that lady from michigan
uh who oh the
witness with giuliani otherwise i mean i
don't necessarily i guess like susan
collins i was sort of and then i will
say
the first time i ever felt like i can do
an impression
was uh sarah koenig because i had
listened to cereal
so much and it was like that's so in my
head and i got to meet her and she was
very like didn't know if we were making
fun of her or not i had to like tell her
over and over like no we love you you're
in my head
for i wouldn't listen to it if i
thought you were a joke how does she
express that to you how does somebody
like sarah kaning well we i trust that
insecurity she was kind of
not
just sort of i recognize it because of
when i have it in myself just feeling a
little
self-conscious and yes not sure
um so then i feel like i had to i then i
probably went overboard to tell her how
much it was probably looked like i was
trying to take her home or something
yeah of course
have you ever had um
any have you ever done anybody to them
on the show have you ever had that
moment uh
stormy daniels was on the show but i
didn't
play her
oh okay i think i played melania that
episode but oh funny
stormy daniels is as close as i've
gotten
what why do people do people come after
you for doing any sort of politicized
thing no no not really i mean even the
one time i i met melania she seemed to
be okay with it and uh
and i think even like when no matter who
i'm playing it's still like we're trying
to do
i'm i'm not a real i don't would not
want to feel like i made somebody feel
terrible about themselves yeah about
something like
that they look
about their looks or something so i
think it's like i don't want to hit
below the belt and i think there's
always something when i'm doing an even
if it's like someone i may
not
love as a human being yeah there's
something that i love that they do
i totally i it was interesting to read
about your brother in the book and um
your experience growing up uh and that
he was he he just seemed like he had
such a hard time obviously he's doing
great now he's found love which is so
nice to hear he seems like a really good
person but that he was so bullied as a
kid i i do you think that informed
your own um
sense of humor and
your own comedic drive oh you know what
probably that probably
has something to do with it but i think
also just
like there are you know the things that
like stick in your head i definitely
when you think about any time you maybe
hurt somebody
especially like as kids when you don't
realize that like
and you've made you know like i can
think of the kids that i wasn't nice to
or something even if it was just one
moment and it's like
totally me up at night you know i know
it just doesn't feel good to hurt
someone
it's maybe like for a split second when
you're in a fight with them but it
doesn't otherwise it's like not a good
feeling
i know even then even even when i do it
on the road if i oh you get a moment of
like
anger i it it never feels it's never
settling it never settles into something
other than like a distaste you know yeah
there's um cecily there's a there's a
great george saunders uh essay that he i
think he's he it was um commencement
speech
for maybe rutgers or something i forget
the school might have been rutgers but
but um it's about that it's all about
his uh
the the regrets that he has the moments
of inaction that he regrets in terms of
standing up for kids or when he was
tacitly participating in any kind of
like
uh
making fun of like
lessening of somebody's
um
agency it's really beautiful i i would i
encourage anyone to read it but it
reminds me of what we're talking about
yeah i have the same
i definitely even like and i think
something
i i am proud of too
it's like of all the things like when i
can think about all the things i'm not
good at and it's like
i could fill three books and then it's
like i can't wait
here's the only thing i'm not good at uh
but then i like i was pretty good i
think at sticking up for people too just
like as a natural like why aren't we all
doesn't this make the most sense and i
remember yeah i wanna
one of my only awards in life was a
happiness club award
i like the way you said that
well because i remember the whole time
being like i don't know what this is and
i don't quite know what it's for and it
was my favorite teacher mrs smith have
been in sixth grade gave it to me and
she was nervous when she gave a speech
and she called me stephanie the whole
time and then i found out it was like
because i
hung out with like
kids with
developmental disabilities at lunchtime
or something and i was like i get an
award for that
i thought i did something cool i thought
i like you know
wrote a great essay
yeah well it is cool i mean looking back
you can probably see how cool that is
like at the time right but it was just
like at the right it was like oh these
i'm gonna go talk to these kids today
you know what was the correspondence
dinner like i've that to me seems like
it potentially the scariest room
imaginable was there anybody that was
that was so intimidating to make fun of
that that was even tough to get through
or was it just like once you were up
there you just kind of like start flying
you know it's probably different because
i'm not a stand-up so i didn't feel
like i
had pressure to be a stand-up and i was
i you know all everything that i was
saying made me laugh a lot and i
and i think it was like i didn't look at
it as like this is a way to further my
career or anything it was like i get
this is a chance to do this with obama
as president and i'm such a i just
thought the world of barack obama and
still do and
was like you know big i had his like i
had a little barack obama sticker on my
purse when he was running for senate and
i remember in california i was like what
does that mean
like well that's barack obama and then
like to sit next to michigan you're
gonna hear about him right so then i was
like it's a
i have to say yes to this because it's
obama and actually
they asked me
in such a weird way my dad texted me and
he said my friend from the tribune asked
if you wanted to do the correspondence
dinner and i thought he meant himself
and i was like cool dad you should do it
like
at a dinner or like go or something he
went no they want you to host it i was
like that can't be real it couldn't have
come through my dad
but somehow it was
um
and it was like i
was in a really low place because i'd
been
dumped earlier and it was like
heartbroken i like had to go to
california for the summer and like live
on the top of a hill and
i was just at a very low place and
they asked me and it was sort of like i
have to say yes because if i i don't
want to say no to something while i'm
feeling like this about myself
and uh
it was something that scared me and so
it was like yes it was distracting and
kind of
lifted me up a bit
in a weird way it's probably a good time
to do something like that it's a good
you know it's probably a good atmosphere
to to do that yes and it was i mean the
other thing i guess was like i was asked
in august and it wasn't until april so
it was oh yeah oh sure i'll do it it'll
i'll figure it out by then future me has
it
yeah yeah future me right now
i think about it yeah
yeah oh i do that all the time um
what is your family's relationship with
your fame and with sn i mean i know you
talk about it in the book a little bit
and uh certainly owen and leta were so
supportive they were always at the shows
and
and i i love how you described that and
their support but
do you have any family members and or
any people in your life that that got
kind of weird with it or or had a
strange relationship with it no i don't
think i do i think um
you know my parents it's fun every now
and then i'll check their facebook or
something and it's like that's where i
can see all the things they may not say
to me all the time
because it's like oh you're proud of me
you like it oh yeah i see you're busted
yeah
yeah totally
oh that's cute that's sweet um what do
they think of schmincke dune they just
premiered on apple tv i got to see it i
can't wait they love it i think uh
you know i made them both watch it in
one sitting
with me
so i think
my mom is like it took her i think she's
enjoyed it more
not sitting next to me
yeah that's the first thing we did when
we see each other so now she's like then
she'll text me about it like i loved
that whatever and i have fun and
actually my grandmother who is 90
late 90s she's my one living
oh relative and she's my mom's stepmom
so not good jane's in my family
[Laughter]
and she's not until she loved it and she
was like
her daughter showed it she said well i
don't have the apple station
but i if i can buy this in any way
because i'd love to support or something
it's really cute what were you watching
as a kid what were your um
what did you grow up really being
inspired by besides uh
well i watched a lot of musicals
obviously on um vhs that's what we'd
rent and my parents loved comedy so like
we had snl commercials my mom
had the gilda special my dad would show
us like mark's brothers and monty python
oh us too
and my brother and i would watch we
watched a lot of comedy in like the
state upright citizens brigade i loved
strangers with candy i guess i was a
little older then and then i think i
think there's a i mean i and i also
loved talk shows and
dating shows like it was you know before
reality tv i was already a reality tv
the best yeah like i gotta get home
and put on more oh my god well they were
such great characters they were the best
characters yeah
ridiculous oh who are your i still feel
that way about reality shows but but
like now it strikes me there's something
even more interesting in a way that the
bachelors and the bachelorettes they all
are vying to be famous to something and
so so they're all like performing right
it's less interesting to me because of
that yeah because of that i s yeah it's
like bad improv well you just know it's
like you this is like just an extension
of instagram to you to be like a brand
whatever person i want to see somebody
who's off their rocker invested in this
it still happens but it's right you're
right it's rich
i will say it's like
every now and then i'll watch bachelor
and i and i do love the first part i
mean i think that's like that
competition and that fear of being sent
home is like you can't fake that
that's very real and that's fun to me
i don't
but then i think like there are
certainly shows where it's
it's it's real and it's there
i do fiancee
oh coltie colton oh my god
that's um
my brother insane one of the funniest
things i've ever seen in my entire life
the the more consuming yeah because
you're lazy and you're fat quality okay
okay
okay that's your opinion
[Laughter]
i remember he she got a car she wanted a
car and she was like i wanted this car
that's a big in balaki yes i follow her
on instagram now oh really amazing i
love it my brother
my brother got me for my birthday you
know that cameo app
um
he got me one from i don't know if you
saw the season with zee ed of course yes
yeah oh
baby i want to keep you a sexy
oh see it
yes yes i love when he would answer
what do you say
he's been on a lot yeah
yeah he um he's so i gotta send it to
you i'll sell he sent me one he sent me
a cameo it was very sweet wow
happy birthday for to justin
it's amazing now did he do it like up
close was it a sexy yes as though it was
in the early videos that rebecca loved
it was it all my god those were great
but then she was sending him once with
the with the crazy uh filter
remember of course yeah yeah just so
many good and angela and michael
obviously oh my god and and um the one
from the pacific northwest who was that
uh michael and um
who that the ukrainians
like this jaw like this
yes
uncle ball i
oh my god i could i was so happy to see
uncle bo survived covet
i know that's like a dark thing right
but i mean
i know i know i love when she says
because i was just in bulgaria and i
noticed this about a lot of barcarians
how the honest how honest they are and
how honest um she was with beau and
she's if you remember that she was
saying goodbye to him and he's like okay
and he's like well maybe uh you know
i'll see him
yeah
she goes no no i will not i will never
see you
no it was there was just something so
like yeah you're not going to see each
other
um oh god they're so good
and these the latin women i can't
believe those men
it's just like i can't believe they are
in these relationships where i'm like
you are so emasculated i'm feeling
awkward watching this also
how i can't what is her name from
michigan oh who goes to belize likes
yes and
and has ryan
and then his cousin wow because now ryan
ryan doesn't wear a robber
so ryan told me is wearing a raw bird he
was yeah that's really good oh these are
expensive undies
and then and
and then he leaves so then she goes with
the cousin well well he uh what the hell
is his like yeah harrison harrison oh
harrison is actually a much better lover
yeah i couldn't believe she's yeah i got
you nice swatches and robbers
like that's how i want to travel from
now on i agree i want to bring someone
underwear undies watches and robbers
that's right and a thousand dollars for
snacks
and there's a hundred she gave him a
hundred dollars for snacks
that's right that's right and then and
then got matt and then and then would
use that then would weaponize that throw
it back in his face so i gave her and
then was giving his family so much i
mean like uh it was i it was dark but
like it's sometimes that's that's a
perfect example of i never know who to
right who's darker in that situation a
lot of them i just think it's like
i think they are like i root for them
and it's like people that
maybe don't that want love and they want
a relationship and it's been hard and
there's just something about like
someone who comes from somewhere else
that
yeah appeals to them and so it's like
aspiration it's not just all like fake
and shitty it's there's something very
sweet too and you root for them
yeah or or it's like harrison now i'm
remembering harrison was just like um i
want to i want to go to america like he
was like pretty honest
uh and she was like
harrison do you think you're ready to
come with me to michigan stephanie that
was her name
stephanie
stephanie that's what i was and she saw
michigan she's so stuff funny i can hula
hoop
pierce ryan loved yeah
that's right something happened with our
company recently where she's getting her
company
yeah she has that like cosmetics
yeah yeah and um they were making false
claims about it being able to prevent
covid i think wow of course something
about it yeah it's very stephanie it's
on brand yeah
wow but harrison's been so supportive um
um i'm sorry
i know i appreciate that i that's i
needed that that's good i love talking
that michigan accent's so good i guess
you grew up near michigan but oh yeah i
mean i very near michigan like an hour
drive or something and everybody who had
any money or what i consider money
growing up had a house in michigan
oh yeah yeah and cars they would say
their cars they had nice cares nice cars
and wisconsin was wisconsin was over
there too lake geneva oh yeah
well
what is um
is that so so you grew up doing that you
grew up knowing how to do you just had
an ear for those well i think it was
like that's how everybody even like
chicago it's sort of similar i mean like
may go a bit harder
like you naturally have that girl yes i
naturally have
the most beautiful uh accent in the
world
yes the most beautiful vowel sounds mom
and dad
did yes i have a little bit connecticut
weirdly has a flat a yeah as well
there's some weird thing like buffalo
every now and then i'll hear buffalo and
i think it's some in chicago
yes me too i and i do that i i like it's
probably a way to show off but i i and
oftentimes i'm right i'm pretty good at
like pinpoint like uh
at at least approximating where
somebody's from and they're and
it's fun i guess it's something that i
like just uh get off on a little bit
where they're like how'd you know that i
um but i did it yesterday for example
and on set and um i said i didn't know
you're from canada i did it really
confidently because somebody had said
sorry
he was so i said oh sorry i didn't mean
to i said i didn't know you're from
canada and he said i'm not why would you
just why would you just say that
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say ooh that's a good one
let's see
well i guess the heart
and then i like um i definitely i like
the dancing lady oh yeah people like
that one yeah i like the clown i like
the cowboy
what context
in what what context you use the cowboy
i guess sometimes if i i use like cowboy
and clown together
like when i'm like know that i'm saying
something kind of goofy
uh-huh
yeah
and the guy with the sunglasses it's
like that's when i'm proud of what i
said sunglasses guy clown cowboy
oh that's funny uh i've been doing a lot
of this one the gridded this guy i do a
lot yes yeah yeah that means
that is a very like very much an emotion
for me like uh-huh
yeah i'm excited about that
yes or i'll say it like if i say
something on instagram that i'm like
that might be taken the wrong way just
know that i also know it's a little like
iffy yeah
either it's unfunny or whatever like uh
um
if you could be a professional athlete
what's what sport would you play oh
soccer handstand soccer yeah yeah that's
so cool that you know those those ladies
megan rappano and they sound really
amazing i didn't know megan rapino was
the first one to kneel yeah at the
anthem that's really cool they're just
yeah they really are diverse in a lot of
ways and that is such like a i hate
saying that
word especially well i don't hate saying
the word i hate saying the word around
certain people and that it's like but i
do think they are in the best way that
it's like there's just they come from
everywhere and they
represent
everyone and they
really stand for it and then they're
really really good they're really good
right yeah it's just fun to watch people
good at what they do in any sport really
even if i'm like i don't get this sport
but wow that guy's really good at
curling no i know uh it's so funny every
four years it's like i get so into these
sports that i and then for the next four
i
kind of forget about but um there's just
you're right there's something about
seeing somebody at that peak physical
form yeah
doing something that you could
technically do i mean we could all
technically do those things
uh huh i don't know that i could even
technically do any of it
well
without hurting myself horribly yeah
yeah um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your life what would it be your
go-to snack food it would either be like
crackers and i make this goat cheese
and garlic and oil cheese i should just
say cheese yeah yeah cheese um
there's some great cheese shop yeah new
york i am now
missing new york for i hate the smell of
really like um strong cheese like
punches yeah yeah like going to paris
it's like well i'm gonna go stop in the
fart shop for a second that's that's it
how do we not people are always so
incredulous with me when i tell them
that i don't like those it's like but it
smells like you smelled farts and
smelled farts and like you know that
it's at least like as you might say
adjacent uh
to a fat
certainly fart adjacent yes yes yeah
um what is your uh
this is a very personal question i i
don't mean to just throw it at you but
do you want to have kids or kids uh do
you think in your future i don't know i
mean it's like biologically it's getting
to be that's like the decisions being
made for me but i still i'm like there
was like a year when i i got my dog and
i'm like i really i love my dog so much
and she's a rescue dog and so so it's
i'm not afraid of adoption as something
but i'm just not i'm just not there yet
yeah yeah no no okay um we i was i was
asking weirdly because i i'm always
curious what what movie people would
want
would be most excited to introduce to
their kids you know like
you know what's the movie that was so
special to you growing up that you're
like oh god it'd be nice to have a kid
one day and show them this that's a
great thought
i don't have that in my head right at
this moment but that's like that's
something that's like fun to think about
and
i know yeah well well think about it
yeah um
yeah i'm curious uh what is your go-to
oh you talk about karaoke singing
karaoke um
and what is your go-to song what is your
like showstopper um i think i normally
can rely on
dreams by the cranberries and something
by patsy cline
oh great yeah i love that song i [ __ ]
love that song i remember it was it was
in the trailer for um boys on the side
remember that trailer oh yeah
i don't remember the chat i like i
didn't remember the movie till you just
said it right now oh man um i love that
song i [ __ ] love it such a great song
it's it's so it's genuinely like a
perfect song
i is it makes you feel some immediately
you hear the beginning
like it's just a perfect song i'm
feeling it now i'm hearing it now and
it's it it really feels like i'm getting
goosebumps yeah yeah this is the most
the best part of this podcast um i i
remember you said yeah again another
great part of the book when you talk
about allowing being able to laugh for
the first time and like enjoy a moment
for the first time in a while and like
um and you guys dancing around the the
upstate house putting on and you put on
the perfect song i love how you
described putting on the perfect song
that lou reed's song yeah um
and they're like and and knowing that
it's bringing joy to people that there's
there is truly i've
lately had that thought oh god it feels
good to put on the perfect song for a
group oh yeah
i i love that um
uh what what
what who was your first celebrity crush
i had like two when i i put a i had a
bulletin board up and then like
other girls i knew had pictures on this
so i was like well i should put i'll put
two pictures
on the bilge mart and i my two
pictures were leonardo dicaprio and brad
renfrow
brad was uh really yeah what a
sad situation awful yeah awful yeah um
sorry sorry
i'm the one who says it but i'm still
like no but i think it's like nice to
he well he was my crush i thought he was
such a good actor and like a cool bad
boy
was a bad boy yeah i lately i've been
saying i like to say i'm the bad boy of
of such inception so like like my
brother was getting like a uh he's gonna
love me telling you this man his fiance
was putting a mask on him last night
like a facial yeah
i said oh you're like the bad boy of
facial masks
like using the bad boy of something um
if if you had to get a tattoo what would
you get i shouldn't i just
shouldn't i mean i guess i could get
you know at this point it would be like
a bird or something to oh obviously yeah
yeah but i used to want like
i wish i could get a tattoo if i if
tattoos lasted for a year i would
do full body tattoos
oh really oh yeah
what would you get in there for the next
year the next coming year i mean
anything i found funny at the moment i i
was like i every now and then i'll see
someone who's got like a full chest
tattoo and i just think it's so pretty
and i'm like i wish i could do that for
a year
i i know yeah me too it's yeah
uh maybe there are there is that the
technology um
or you can develop it uh i'm gonna spend
the rest of my life developing yeah
temporary tattoo
uh what is what is your favorite fruit
would you say favorite fruit
strawberries yeah perfect easy
strawberries okay um
who do you want to play you in your
biopic i
me i don't know um yeah yeah you should
um
strawberries are also pretty easy to
grow strawberries i'm starting to grow
them but i think they're not like are
they super easy i thought you have to
like anything that takes an extra step
is kind of i go like i don't know
anymore if i'm going to grow these
things i think it's like thin them out
right and it's like a next year crop
it is well mine are growing from last
season but i say that only because
cecily i i love gardening but i'm
if i can do it truly i'm not being
selfish no no i believe you yeah
yeah did you move your strawberries are
you just like you started to grow them
last year and now they're growing back
and you have strawberries
they're grown back okay great and then
like i have wild strawberries up in
massachusetts and
um but they're the little kind of like
uh they're different they're not like
obviously
like two big juicy ones they're kind of
like little i know yeah
but good yeah
yeah okay delicious and again that like
you say like you describe the feeling of
just picking anything yes and it's fresh
like the yes you don't realize how much
a difference that makes i know i know um
uh who is your favorite muppet growing
up probably miss piggy
yeah for sure yeah
um do you do those voices at all i don't
know why i'm so hung up on your voices i
think you do great impressions well i'm
sorry that i keep i feel like i don't
know them well enough but i feel like
there was a moment with there was one
day we were all kind of joking with
melissa via senor and she was like it
was like melissa meeting kermit i was
like hey melissa oh hey kermit that sort
of thing
that's really funny she's she does have
a little of that in her voice and then i
feel like my dog is a little like miss
piggy i can't do a grain but it's just
like
yeah yeah
my dog hits a lot and her affection
involves like hitting you
ah that's cute
what what kind of dog is it the rescue
but what do you know what roughly uh she
look she's like part rat part pig i
think she's got she's definitely a
spaniel mix and i know she has have an
ease in her from the two dna tests that
i gave her
i give myself three my dog too my
parents won
i've got identity issues yeah he's got
to say something i don't want to dig too
deep but uh
what is your go-to pizza topping cheese
and garlic and more cheese
oh yeah great um you would love a place
here called pepes pepe's in in
connecticut have you been there no
pepe's is in there there are a couple
now there's one it's the originals in
new haven but um they have a great
summer pie if you're in connecticut i
mean the thing is like i don't know how
many i don't know that i've met a pizza
i don't like yet
yeah yeah i hear you uh dogs are cats
dogs
yeah you see uh beetles are the rolling
stones i'm going to say beetles that my
i have a big beatles family and i just
the other night had like a fun beatles
night
uh that hulu if you could
right now you're at a bar what are the
first few songs like what would you put
on if you were there with letty and owen
and your friends what would you want to
hear sure i think i would i
always loved like let it be that album
yeah um but i also like come together
i listen and then i listen to a lot of
john lennon
alone too i love
yoko um
but beatles i mean anything white album
and yeah and uh
i love the full let it be
yes i did the full album i was just
talking about the white album how
disparate the the songs how how um
how varied those those you're prudence i
mean like today what i would love is
dear prudence whenever there's like a
storm i remember like being in chicago
and if there was like a big thunderstorm
just putting on dear prudence felt like
oh this is so cinematic wow totally once
you come out to play yeah
you know cecily that's about um i think
it's about
when they were in india you know they
wrote that song because of mia farrow
and her and her sister her younger
sister who apparently was
even more charming than she was um
prudence wouldn't come out wouldn't uh
wouldn't come out of her room she was
just like meditating the whole time she
was there to meditate with a maharaji
and like all the rock stars donovan all
the beatles whoever was there was like
they all wanted a you know murder come
out please yeah yeah
stop meditating for a second prudence i
i heard another one you'd like about
sexy sadie which is oh my god yes thank
you and actually so my i have a
connection with that one because
my very good friend shane who i was
close with in high school and i'm still
close with but when i was dropping out
and really depressed he made me a great
mixtape and it had sexy sadie on it and
i just remember
listening to it over and over me too
yeah falling in love with that song and
feeling kind of like it was dangerous
and sexy obviously yeah um i had so many
yeah it's such a great association with
it but and so maybe this isn't good to
hear like where do songs come from but i
just learned a friend of mine told me
that um
because they're reading a book about the
beatles that it was it was
it was lenin's like disillusionment with
the maharaji um
in in india because he saw that the
maharaja he had held him up to be this
like
you know pillar of spirituality and and
in fact the maharaja just wanted to like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like yeah yeah he just
wanted to get his
groove on it a lot of religions
yeah end up being like that
girls and stuff and um so the original
lyric was maharajji wow
so if you listen to that song now in
that context it's really interesting you
made a fool of everyone
uh you you um
you made a yeah
it was actually like a negative thing
and
that's
really cool i also
i think about i really love across the
universe but i love yeah fiona apple's
version and i think like i read
somewhere like john lennon was never
happy with any of the recordings and but
they put that one on the album
anyway and i like to think that john
lennon would have been like that's it
with fiona apple's version oh wow yeah
yeah i wonder that about covers i asked
um on the show i asked sara bareilles
about that about doing a cup of somebody
she does a great yellow brick road if
you ever say goodbye y'all i love sara
bareilles too i mean wow
this will melt your heart this
version of it and and um
but she she described that it being like
but she also was like very confident in
it in the song but when she played it
for elton john yeah and and i was she
was like he was nice about it i was like
i think he was because it made it better
it was like we were watching that
whitney houston documentary last night
and like i i i wonder how dolly pardon
feels about what whitney houston did to
you know
i feel like she must
she must love it you have to
yeah if whitney houston sang anything
that i'd ever
been close to i'd love it i'd brag about
it for the rest of my life
you have to um
okay well man that's a sorry about that
tangent um
uh ketchup
back to the usual boring super mustard
yeah i'm a chicago gal i gotta say
mustard
oh yeah okay spicy mustard then huh
mm-hmm
i just find i used it even if it's like
if i ever use ketchup i'm mixing mustard
in ah okay i've been using a lot more in
cooking like i i made a meatloaf
in in like a glaze or something
it's great you'll yeah and when it's
like you'll never use ketchup in cooking
and if you are you're
doing you're not you're not yeah you're
not making food for me you should be
disowned by any italian relative yes
that you have um uh well this was this
was so fun cecily i i uh again i can't
thank you enough for this book it's it's
i can't and we're going to encourage
people to again i'm bob wiley with baby
steps um
it's the horse sex
you are stinky
that's funny um it's really beautiful
really honest and um i just so thank you
thank you for sharing uh your experience
thank you and thank you for reading it
and having me on i'm so glad i i was
i've been a fan of yours for a while uh
and so i'm glad likewise i feel like
we've always gotten along yeah we have
yeah i think we have i can't wait to you
got a good spirit to you kid yeah
likewise pal um
yeah truly this has been really two bad
boys
that's
that's right i'm the bad boy of just a
couple of bad boys yeah bad boys of
conversation
um well thanks thanks for doing this
thank you yes yes
so that happened
oh my god that happened
well that's no i was trying to do
she has a little i wasn't doing her i
was doing like her doing a character
uh what character um
it's the uh overdone cecily strong
impression uh-huh it was she's kind of
like she's got a natural
uh chicago it's not nearly it's not
that's not nearly yeah i don't know why
i want to do like because she does
very like it's hard to do a subtle maybe
it's this it's hard to do a subtle
chicago accent
you kind of have to lean into it well
yes so that so that happened happened
but you can hear it
right i could hear it yeah for sure but
i'm i'm not good at impressions so i
can't do well i guess i'm i'm not either
that happened
that happened it's hard you're right
it's hard it is it's hard to do a
subtle shock of it you know who has a
subtle chicago um
is jake johnson in french
i would say his is stronger yeah uh she
it also has kind of like this is just
maybe sound insulting i don't know how
else to say this she has kind of like a
a lazy yeah voice yeah like kind of like
lorraine and um
older lorraine and backpack
oh my god
uncle joey didn't make parole oh yeah oh
my gosh she does she does sound like
that a little bit just a little bit
yeah
there's something also relaxing about
her voice i think
yeah i found it very relaxing um
and and she is as you can hear i thought
she's very honest she's very
she's great i i really liked her
she's like friend goals for me like i
want to be your friend oh that's
interesting i like you know what i
really like when really funny people
don't try to be funny totally it's the
best yeah and then because then it comes
out organically exactly there and then
you you know there's not even a hint of
performance that's true which is really
nice and refreshing it was like um very
it was present without being um you're
right performative it's like she has
nothing to prove you know it's like yeah
she knows she's funny and that sometimes
she's just not hammy that can sometimes
that can like
um that can trip me up a little bit
sometimes when somebody is uh
it very because it demands
the equal and equal amount of presence
from you right and that's that can be
intimidating
and it's um
yeah and it made me want to
for sure made me want to read her book
uh and i'm impressed that you didn't do
a book report because i know how into
the book you were working i got i
thought i had oh really yeah oh good i
didn't think you did so in fact to the
point where i kind of wish you had a
little bit just so i like knew a bit
more i wish okay that's good to know i
mean i pieced it together i figured out
that
her cousin had passed away and yeah i
surrendered the pandemic but i didn't
really know i i didn't
i i should have done my own research
what should i have should we have done
more in the intro no about the book do
we do enough
yeah i mean you talked about what you
wrote during the pandemic and yeah her
cousin it's journal form it's um but
then she goes back in time and she she
she uses the pandemic and the death of
her cousin is kind of like a
a catalyst to examine her own life in
her own past it's
again it's like
i i said this to her when we were
talking but there's something very
strange about i don't think i
expressed how strange it felt to to know
so much about somebody such personal
details about somebody and and i
intimate like oh my god like her uh
thoughts on death and her experiences
with death and her parents and
how she feels about her
loved ones who passed away and and
herself and like moments of like
weakness that she's very honest about in
the book she talks about like she did i
we talked about this she details i
thought this was interesting all the
texts um that she wanted to send to this
guy
that that was like withholding affection
from her and um
and i thought some of them are i mean
they're funny they're but they're like
there's a i can see how they might be
perceived as as embarrassing i can see
how they might cause embarrassment
but she's she really like puts it all
out there and i yeah
i thought that was interesting that she
said that she considers herself a shy
yeah i know introvert
but once she's you know comfortable
um with someone or in a situation she's
like an open book yeah it's strange that
someone that funny
um would be shy would ever describe
themselves as being shy for but but she
did seem a bit introverted near the
beginning of the conversation right yeah
someone who is that funny that good at
impressions and making people laugh
professionally it's strange when that
person is
introverted it is strange i know
but it makes me feel like she puts it
all out there you know like i think
there's something a little bit more um
i don't know authentic about her
skills as a performer mm-hmm is that
what it is maybe
or it's just what maybe it's like not
even worth examining that it's just like
a certain type of person that like they
perform i mean when they perform they
perform and
uh all that the death talk made me
realize because you know i'm scared of
death you know both of you scared of
death um
but i realized that
you know getting to a point in your life
where
not only are you not scared of it but
you're
open to the idea of it and like
comfortable with it happening not that
you want it to happen getting to that
place
mentally and emotionally when it comes
to death feels like
by far the biggest goal i know of my
life like i know if if that's
the one thing that i really like the one
goal that i set out and i accomplish it
that's by far the best news
that i could have i you know i feel the
same way like how do you get to that
point i think meditation helps we talked
about that on the michael pollan episode
this letting go of the ego i mean that's
those the people who did the psilocybin
treatments with the michael pollan that
he talks about in his book um who were
who were facing death the ones that
overcame their fear of death i think did
so by removing themselves from the ego
divorcing yourself from like the the
attachment to life so you're telling me
just to do a bunch of drugs yeah do
mushrooms and meditate you know my i
speak in the michael pollan episode mom
texted me the other day she said um
something like i can't get my earbuds to
work oh my phone so
everyone around me on my walk had to
listen to uh your podcast
michael pollan episode and she wrote
ps don't do any more
mushrooms that's because i guess i had
said that oh really did it yeah i kind
of remember that she just says another
funny one about her ear bud what's wrong
with her earbuds why can't she figure
that out she just said um
she wrote to both of us out of nowhere
this is unrelated to anything i charged
the earbuds put them in my ears turned
on your podcast no sound through buds
now what
and you said i have to show you in
person all right i feel like doing tech
support for them has become
almost my full-time job now it's every
day there's something i know we're like
it's definitely a part-time job well and
the funny part is that pro bono we are
wildly unqualified for it yeah we're
terrible with technology nine times out
of ten she'll ask me something and i
don't want to be rude but i want to say
first google that because or first
unplug it and plug it back in or turn it
off turn it on beyond that i don't
really know how to fix things family
feud she said what time's your show on
i'm just reading back through text
give me time station for feud please
sending info to friends and fam it's
like
look it up but you know ultimately this
is our fault because we're the ones who
haven't
properly left the teat as it was i know
i know we got a follow-up tag sorry to
put that in your head
that's gross
i've uh i could have said the nest i l
apparently i left the teeth sooner than
you did we don't have to get into it now
everyone knows that okay well we just
can cut it out no it's funny who cares
not much sooner or later
i don't want to talk about it too much
but i think uh i was attached to the
cheat for
like a really inappropriate amount of
time could you ask with words can i ask
her no no could you at the time of the
teat attachment this is so disgusting
and i can't believe you'd be like hey
mom i would like she was like oh you
would ask for oh
man isn't that horrible uh we shouldn't
shame people who do do that but i know
that there's no shame in the game also
in fairness i was the last her last
child so i think yeah it's not that i it
was i think it's she didn't want to let
go she didn't want to let go of the
teeth neater right you know i really
want to talk to this about um not her uh
but alicia silverstone
because she fed her child
uh i think
bird stuff bird baby bird style shut up
i swear to you she mastic are you
supposed to repeat that no she works
about it
like to you because you're her friend no
no it's she's spoken about it publicly
oh really i in fact if she like
advocates for it i think wow i think
she's like into it
well our guest today cecily strong
doesn't have children it's true even
though you asked her is that rude yeah i
think so i think that's a faux pas wait
i didn't seem bothered by it but i asked
if she wanted children i'm pretty no i
think that's a faux pas oh it is i think
so
yeah you can i mean you weren't like
when are you gonna have i mean you
didn't like pressure her or nothing no
but i was but i think you're not
supposed to ask women
uh it was funny how you kept trying to
prompt her to do impressions
and uh you were like i know i know well
like the sarah caning thing but then
as luck would have it you happened to
mention 90 day fiance and she like
completely lit up she lit up and did all
the impressions it was amazing i know i
could i was so glad it made me realize
it made me think that
the two of you
should have a podcast about 90 day
fiance oh man that'd be funny
well you should be on it well i i could
maybe pop in here and there but if it
was the two of you that would be really
funny
doing impressions of them analyzing the
episodes oh that's a great idea isn't it
because those episodes as you know are
so rich
they like really deserve like
i haven't seen it in a while
look so christian we talked about that
how you got me this yeah thing for my
birthday yeah yes it's gonna be tough to
beat because she does a very good uh
that was funny god she's really good
she's really good and she got she nailed
that i mean like that's the thing about
impressions is there's a um
there is something
very clear there's like a like an anchor
to an impression and in the case of that
woman who's with mike that doesn't open
her mouth she doesn't open her mouth
like this and it informs everything
comes from that yes it's a really
interesting quirk and she i think i'm i
think the best people do that dana you
know we mentioned we talked about dana
carvey and those guys but i usually find
something that like stands out as being
unique she is i would say it's
interesting that she likes phil hartman
as much as she does because i
think that's she's the best um like the
closest
current cast member
to what phil hartman was then i agree
you know because he would do a lot of i
mean they're both great at impressions
and they're both
attractive
yeah and when you're attractive it's
hard sometimes it's harder to play
characters so the impressions tend to be
much more specific and they play like
more regular
yeah ordinary looking people
but they find such
great nuance in those
more normal people
it does and and it's that um
and i it i think it requires more
confidence uh to do that to do something
a little bit more nuanced especially on
on that a show like that where you want
to
you know you want to really make an
impact you want to be seen you want to
especially now and i can think of some
some performers on that show who really
like swing for the fences but um
phil hartman and cecily i would say
there's something more nuanced about
their approach to impressions um should
we read
a letter oh one little nitpicky thing
before that um you said new haven new
haven
new haven i think
it's new haven i said new haven but then
i started thinking why is it new haven
new york because it's new york yeah new
york you don't say new york new york say
new york new haven
do you hear the difference yeah well i
don't know why i don't either that's
what i was wondering new york you knew
why
all right
all right god ever since dave keckner i
can't stop now and go right all right
from blair sayer
subject bladder bros and a would you
rather great
g'day good day justin christian hi guys
my name is blair and i'm a long time
listener and now long time letter writer
this is my third shot so we'll see how
we go wow
kind of curious about the other two
blair uh we didn't read the i don't
think we read the first two no no she's
saying she's a long time letter writer
oh so she you think oh blair
i think i should do this i know uh blair
underwood's a man that's true blair
cohen is the age blair thomas is a man
oh yeah
blair
uh linda blair that's last name you're
right maybe it's a okay it's probably a
woman let's see let's see if there are
other clues
i'm a woman oh
really no no i'm kidding
as i was saying really i realized you
were
your face all right back to blair
uh whatever they may be
at presents i am in week four of an
eight week coveted lockdown in western
sydney australia
but i'm originally from new zealand
justin you have my full blessing to
butcher any accents oh man yes lockdown
sucks but it is what it but it is what
it is and things could be worse for sure
i am a freelance illustrator and i have
plenty of work a lot of beers and heaps
of good tv to get through if anything
else i can't do it if anything this last
couple of years has taught me it's to
keep looking for the silver linings
last year i dealt with my own issues
with having two tumors removed from my
bladder
i was literally turning 48 at the time
the surgery was performed on my birthday
oh my god and although scary and a crazy
thing to deal with i came out all okay
that's good to hear player the cancer
was aggressive but non-invasive and they
got it all
at a good time um i have had clear
results from checkups since touch wood i
will touch wood
that's why they say touchwiz yeah knock
on wood yeah i didn't know that um
and they say we say touch wood down
under as opposed to your knock on wood
perfect time for an innuendo injection
perfect time for an innuendo injection
that's funny
um
uh yeah no yeah it would be if we could
uh also because of the obvious entry and
exit point with male bladder surgery
male 1 okay wow i have had to laugh when
less informed friends of mine have asked
if i have a scar
uh okay so
that's funny um because i see i i would
have asked too i'd be a less informed
friend of his
would there be a scar
no
also because of the obvious entry and
exit point with male bladder surgery i
have had to laugh with less when less
informed friends of mine have asked if i
have a scar you understand what he's
saying right yeah so yeah
it's it's inside it's
the penis
i think that's how you get in there they
go through the europe i think so
okay okay
back to the letter
my point here is as an older man who
loves your show i'm also very empathetic
to your pea talk justin and nodded and
laughed along at your conversation with
nick frost there is no rule broke with
life and everyone is different but at
some stage men cross a threshold and
find they pee differently especially at
night it's something not talked about
often enough in my opinion so thanks for
your honesty here
i
can't believe that that had a positive
effect on somebody so someone in
australia is all the way in there yeah i
know
um that's
amazing uh it's something i tell you
it's a big part of what makes your
podcast so great and i find the laughing
out loud parts good for my body and the
honest part's good for my soul keep the
great shows coming fellas you both seem
very modest but i hope you know your
show touches something in a lot of
people god that's so nice blair that's
so nice thank you blair sayer
what a kind thing um
okay anthony would you rather all right
would you rather have the best night's
sleep of your life
every night but never dream again
oh wait wait uh sleep or every night but
never okay so would you rather have the
best night's sleep of your life every
night but never dream again or
never have a great night's sleep ever
again but dream all the time you do
sleep and remember all your dreams oh
yeah
yeah definitely i
i don't really care about dreams i mean
dreams are cool cool but i feel like my
dreams are more often
unsettling in some way or weird or
if i'm nervous about something i have
like anxiety anxiety dreams like i
didn't do uh
i didn't prepare for a big test or
something so you don't often have like
or like an actor's nightmare i don't
know my lines on in a play yeah i have
those friends the worst i have those a
lot i have those always before uh
the first day of work i rarely let me
put it this way i rarely have dreams
where i wake up and i think
oh no
i want to go back to that yeah that was
amazing i love that dream i haven't had
one of those it doesn't happen a lot for
me i don't know what that says about my
life
no or your subconscious that's what i'm
saying uh all right well so definitely
yeah i i would too and and
nothing beats it to have us right now to
sleep every night just talking our
friend james about that how
reaching a certain age how
important sleep is like how
how how important it's become in my life
and i never thought a good night's sleep
i mean i you know it was always like
yeah take it or leave it i preferred
good nights right but now it's like
one of my favorite things to do and it
cut and it changes the whole day the
next day exactly you get the such a
great day afterwards um okay apart from
back to the letter apart from my night
being i am blessed with both wow lucky
you i've managed to sleep like a baby uh
all most of my life and frequently dream
and remember most of them god it's so
lucky blair that's great
um stay safe guys and keep up the great
podcasting i'd buy you both a beer today
if i could just to say thanks for what
you're doing not a fosters by the way no
one here in australia drinks fosters
i've heard that i've heard really i
didn't know that yeah that's like an
american australian it's like the ad
campaign has tricked us into believing
totally it's like all the directions
that's funny not a foster's by the way
uh i'd like to have a beer with him i
would too cool he does um and
i really am not saying that because he
likes the show but i'm sure that's
influenced you i'm sure
i'm sure because this show is we've
talked about this it's like if somebody
says and conversely if somebody says
they don't like the show it's hard to it
would be hard to think that they're cool
well forget cool it's just like someone
you don't have a beer with yeah exactly
yeah somebody that you would that would
get see because i would be thinking the
whole time they don't want to have a
beer with me
yeah
so i'd be self-conscious but um that's
that makes sense yeah so if you do like
the show i would say there's about
anybody who likes the show i'd want to
have a beer with them
uh i have a very low bar but but blair
god blair what a great letter and um i
i'd love to hear
how you're doing i hope he keeps writing
i
hope he continues to feel better i do
too and if you guys want to write into
the show our email address is live
dot com
and
oh and also check out uh cecily
schmidtoon yes with um
a friend of the show fred armisen yes i
already see that i do but it's really
good great cast and um it's on apple tv
and please read her book i i you will
not be disappointed what's the name
again it is called this will all be over
soon
and uh this podcast will all be over
soon too oh great that will all be over
just this episode
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and co-produced by
you christian law it's also produced by
megan v monaco senior producer is
michelle miesh lans audio engineer is
sergio enriquez and the executive
producer is a manned
man
it's a he's a man he is a man he
identifies that way still i think i
believe he does marshall
louie for wondering
[Music]
oh that's right i'll hear that that
sounds funny yeah it's not a real one
but it's like a joke okay that's kind of
what we've been telling one day
there was this woman in the car
you are not allowed to have penguins in
your car take it to the zoo
and then the next day
same car
the same penguin in the car
okay
she never took it to the zoo and the cop
said i told you to take it to the zoo
and then the woman said
i did and he liked it this time we're
going to the beach
that's really funny
that's really funny did you get it percy
did you hear that
oh the last part is um the cop said hey
i thought i told you to take that
penguin to the zoo and and the lady who
was driving said i did and the penguin
liked it so much next time we're gonna
go to the beach
she just took the penguin to see the
animals in the zoo not to be part of the
zoo
[Music]
[Laughter]
you